helping to design every step the
astronauts take as Christy Hansen the
space walking task lead for the Hubble
servicing mission
well this mission is very exciting
because what we're doing on this flight
is five back-to-back spacewalks
typically on orbit who is well maybe
before and are not back-to-back it's a
very heavily packed mission so
essentially on any hubble space
telescope servicing mission we're either
gonna fix broken science instruments on
the telescope or we're gonna upgrade
leading the highly skilled team of
spacewalkers is veteran hubble astronaut
John Grunsfeld this is John's third
mission to the Hubble joining John for
three of the spacewalks is rookie
astronaut drew foist 'el another Hubble
veteran Mike Massimino will be making
his second visit to the telescope he'll
be joined on two of the spacewalks by
another first-time astronaut Mike good
on the first spacewalk John and drew
will change out the white field camera
this new camera is the highest science
priority on the mission and it's a big
improvement over the old one with the
addition of infrared arrays the camera
will be able to look much farther into
the distant universe and continue to
provide the stunning images that Hubble
is known for it will take a little over
two hours to swap cameras one of the
biggest challenges for the astronauts on
this spacewalk is hand fatigue from
constantly fighting the pressures of
their suits while gripping the cameras
for such a long period of time near the
end of the first spacewalk they'll
change out the batteries this is the
first time batteries have ever been
replaced on the telescope giving Hubble
fresh new Power Cells there are two
modules that contain three batteries
each John will work on replacing one set
while drew changes out the other
for the second spacewalk
the teams are switched Mike good is on
the robotic arm and Mike Massimino will
be the free floater they're changing out
the six gyroscopes that help keep the
telescope properly oriented in space
it's a challenging task because the
doors they need to get into are unevenly
shaped and once inside it's a tight fit
a giant guy in his spacesuit jammed in
this they called the x-ray off and he's
not allowed to touch anything inside of
the Astra none of the black multi-layer
insulation
there's cabling and harnesses that giant
is a giant guy now the most exciting
parts of the missions will be spacewalks
number three and four we do spacewalks
normally everything is designed to be
performed by an astronaut wearing big
beefy gloves so the bolt sizes are nice
and bangs got a big nice socket on it
and everything is captive so when you're
released up with doesn't float away well
we're getting into an instrument the
Space Telescope imaging spectrograph
stopped working on the Hubble in August
of 2004 when a power supply failed but
before that happened it was able to
confirm for the first time the existence
of a black hole in the center of a
galaxy the spectrograph can measure how
fast a star or planet is moving and what
it's made of
to get to this critical piece of
hardware the astronauts will need to
remove a cover that is held in place
with lots of tiny screws 111 or 11 on
fact non captive screws and the s
critters are gonna be floating around
you got you actually have to design a
tool to make it happen
and I can show you what that down here
on the moment let's see it this is
called the Space Telescope imaging
spectrograph fastener capture plate and
it's a beefy tool pretty impressive
this whole thing we snap on to the front
of the science instrument so it's it's
on top of the cover we have to remove
and if you look closely it's a lexan
cover and there are 111 holes in this
and what that allows us to do is to
access the screws on the cover of the
science instrument now these screws are
they Phillips head screws or these
standard screws or what is it crazy
screws there's three different kinds and
most of them are Torx head screws horses
those are really funky bit really funky
bit we have torque set and everything is
color-coded on the fastener capture
plate to help the astronaut and the
ground team to communicate and not be
confused so the astronaut puts the red
sockets onto his mini power tool sticks
the the socket or fit through itto
releases the screw and then the screws
are all floating around inside the
fastest at plate and covered so they
won't be free inside the telescope with
a new bed